the way I handle things even though the
few rare days when I really struggle I
take a real step back and make pretend
that somebody called me and told me that
my mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I can make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
if something bad happened to the people
I love the most that it would mean
nothing and it very consistently rewires
me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day for me it's not
really money it's my legacy I put in
perspective and you know what up until I
had a daughter even while I was married
up until when I had Misha four years ago
I secretly wanted to lose all my money I
had this weird twisted dark fantasy of
losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind you I'm a
humungous believer that ideas are shot
and that executions the game we've all
got ideas everybody's got ideas doing
ideas we all have here we can probably
sit here for the next two hours draw
them all out record them and predict the
next 78 great startups over the next
nine years there is way too much fodder
brought to the idea Hoover was magic cab
three years earlier uber is not an idea
uber existed it's called magic cab but
the guys that executed sucked so they
lost if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea I'd
like to suffocate it because I think the
actual situation is what you actually do
with it
you just watched two amazing clips from
Gary Vaynerchuk take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]